I should probably address
this public health experts are
citing certain so-called super
spreader events as playing
an important role in the
spread of the Corona virus.
That's right.
You probably heard about this.
A February biotech conference
in Boston has been linked to
20,000 cases and the recent
Sturgis motorcycle rally in
South Dakota may be linked
to as many as 250,000 cases.
Yeah. Well guess what?
It turns out.
There've been way more super
spreading events than we ever
knew.
Tones of them events like the
opening of the used Kleenex
ball, pit and Atlanta.
Yeah, in retrospect, not a good idea.
How about this Miami beaches?
Senior citizen arm wrestling championship.
spoiler alert, There were no winners.
A Chicago radio station held
a how long can you keep your
tongue on an essential workers?
Face shield Competition.
Yeah, Yeah,
Classic Chicago
classic Chicago. Leave it to Chicago.
The Republican national
conventions kissing booth.
I don't know what they were thinking
now, Matt Damon, I know his
heart's in the right place,
but Matt Damon's water conservation
charity started encouraging
people to reuse each other's
gargle water.
Ah, man.
And finally San Diego's annual phlegm-con
they probably should have
canceled it this year.
Yeah, the, I was booked,
but I said no way.
Good for you, Andy
and Andy is a perennial car.
Andy you've gone to phlegm-con every year.
I really have.
It's great. It's gross, but it's great.
Yeah, Well, I'm glad you
sat it out this year.
Old gem.
Thank you, Conan.